et je vous remercie en tout cas d'être
aussi nombreux ce matin puisque vous
êtes une centaine d'entreprises avoir
répondu à l'appel de top départ pour une
journée riche en découvertes jeudi 31
mars une journée de rencontre B2B est
organisée au vélo drumes national entre
des entreprises yvelinoises et des
donneurs d'ordre des Jeux Olympiques et
par olympiques de Paris 2024 le
programme de la journée donc se déroule
en on va dire en trois temps ce matin
donc présentation des différents
donneurs d'ordre pour la avant la
rencontre en B2B de chacun qui se
déroule l'après-midi et en parallèle des
ateliers pour les entreprises et
notamment des ateliers pour aider les
entreprises à essayer de comprendre
comment on peut répondre non pas seul
parce que parfois on n'a pas la taille
critique mais répondre en consortium
avec avec plusieurs entreprises dans
cette salle c'est le speed meeting près
de 90 entreprises y viennoises dans les
secteurs de la sécurité de la
restauration et de la logistique ont
présenté leurs activités le but se
démarquer et retenir l'attention des
donneurs
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est du sourcing
ce qu'on appelle du sourcing qualifié
c'est-à-dire partir à l'encon des chefs
d'entreprise non seulement leur
expliquer les marchés qui vont les
appels d'or qui vont être lancés et où
se situe nos besoins et ensuite c'est de
les rencontrer l'une des ambitions
fixées par la direction des Jeux
Olympiques et de favoriser l'accès aux
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire on est un petit peu un des
outils de ces deux grands organisateurs
des Jeux pour atteindre leurs
engagements donc voilà ils ont pris des
engagements sur le plan environnemental
et social et donc du coup nous on les
aide à atteindre ces engagements
prochain rendez-vous le 7 juin cette
fois-ci pour faire découvrir à des
étudiants du digital collège les
disciplines qui seront pratiqués aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
Paris 2024